This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences
[music] of the individual. Results vary
and may not be typical. We do not make
any claims regarding health [music] or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available.
>> [music]
>> We are honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics, Dr. Joel
Wallach, Bachelor [music] of Science in
Plant and Soil Sciences, Doctor of
Veterinary Medicine, Post Doctorates in
Pathology, Naturopathic Doctor.
>> [music]
[music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. [music]
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual. Results
vary and may not be typical.
>> [music]
>> We do not make any claims regarding
health or income. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We are honored to continue to
share the teachings of a founding father
of the science of epigenetics, Dr. Joel
Wallach, Bachelor of [music] Science in
Plant and Soil Sciences, Doctor of
Veterinary Medicine, four
post-doctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
>> [music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. [music]
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual. Results
vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding [music] health
or income. As an empowered individual,
you do have options available. We are
honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics, Dr. Joel
Wallach, Bachelor [music] of Science in
Plant and Soil Sciences, Doctor of
Veterinary Medicine, four
post-doctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
>> Hello and welcome everyone. Welcome to
Daily with Doc and Becca. My name is
Ruth Ellen Sanchez and I will be your
host for today. We want to give a big
shout out to Rebecca Dukes who is out
visiting with her family and helping
with some situations there.
And um
loving on her family, that's what she's
doing. So we love you Rebecca.
Um also this program is for educational
purposes only and is not meant to treat,
diagnose, or cure any diseases, nor is
it intended to replace the care of your
primary physician.
The statements in this program have been
evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials are
shared as individual experiences of the
individual. Results may vary and may not
be typical.
We do not make claims for income or
health.
And as an empowered individual, you do
have options available.
I am so excited today that we have Dr.
Judy Reynolds and she is going to talk
about a topic that we all find um near
and dear to our heart, epigenetics.
And I can't wait to hear what she has to
say and all of the um
questions that people are going to ask
and different things.
So Dr. Judy is here and she is a
renowned expert in animal nutrition with
a PhD specializing in nutrition
while her focus has been on our equine
friends, her deep understanding of
animal physiology and the importance of
proper nutrition offers a valuable
insight that can be applied to human
health as well.
So, I'm going to go ahead and bring Dr.
Judy on the screen with me and welcome,
welcome, welcome, Dr. Judy. I am very
excited about today if you can't tell.
>> [laughter and gasps]
>> Thank you. You're welcome. Very glad to
be here.
As usual, we have a lot of fun.
Yes, we do.
We do.
So, um
you're going to talk about epigenetics.
I'm very excited.
And um I think you had questions for
everybody.
Well, I thought today, just for fun,
maybe we'd start and anybody who wants
to, I would like to have you just give
me a real quick definition of what you
think epigenetics is and there's no
right or wrong answer. Um one of the one
of the very successful teaching methods,
I believe and that I've used a lot,
is kind of asking or trying to find out
where what your people are thinking
about or what their knowledge is on a
topic before you start. And that way it
helps you decide what you want to spend
your time on and how you want to teach
it. And then afterwards, you know, you
can kind of summarize and see if people
have changed their mind, learned
something, something like that. So, if
anybody in the group there or anybody
online would like to just say, "Well,
I've heard of epigenetics, but here
here's what I think it means." And let's
just pull some of those definitions
together. And then I'll go ahead and
I've got a PowerPoint presentation.
Okay, excellent. We're going to start
with A.J.
I'd like to give the first wrong answer
of the day,
and that will be epigenetics
is
how
lifestyle and environmental factors
uh
toxins and nutrition
etc.
uh
can affect
DNA
but does not change
the underlying DNA itself.
Okay, excellent.
And here's what we're going to find.
Um I've got some definitions that I'm
going to pull up, too, and they're
different. Was that right? Well, like
there's no right or wrong
because there are different ways to do
it. Let me Let me jump in here now
because you brought up a you brought up
a great point.
Uh and Dr. Wock, that's in his
definition in his book.
Okay. Um
not
um doing something
but not affecting the actual sequence of
the DNA.
And that's what you're saying. You're
saying environmental effects that do not
affect the actual genetic sequence of
the DNA. And that is one way to look at
it. Okay?
It's not wrong.
But we're about to hear a better answer,
I see. Well,
no, not necessarily. Okay, anybody else
want to jump in?
Because when we have to think about it
ahead of time, sometimes it you know, it
helps us to really start thinking about
it. If we have to actually If you don't
If nobody wants to answer, that's fine.
There's plenty of answers in the chat.
Yeah, let's have a few from the chat.
That'd be great.
>> So, Sherry Browning says how behaviors
and environment can change the way your
genes work.
And then Keely says, death of genetic
theory.
Um, and then Marilyn says,
are you just giving a definition there
Marilyn? Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Let me see, is there anybody else?
>> Yeah, I just gave Dr. Wallach's
definition. And then I I put down on the
bottom what AJ just said or what um
Dr. Judy just said. Okay. All right,
perfect.
Did you have something else to say?
No, that's still a hand. I'm sorry.
Okay, and then Albert, let's bring you
on and you can
say what you think.
>> Judy.
Hi.
So So my thought to that is pretty
direct and what I understand what the
way Dr. Wallach explained it each time.
And that it's got simply nothing to do
with
uh
what we know as genetics. So, your eye
color, your hair color, your height,
your width, and all of that is that that
is genetics.
But Dr. Wallach explained it very
clearly that it is
the um
a reason The reason is because of the
diets we eat. It's got It's got It's a
nutritional deficiency
that has caused all these problems in
our lives and it's not carried over from
one family to another when you've got a
heart disease or a liver disease and all
of that sort of thing. It's purely
because of our diets that we have
these problems in our lives.
And that's the direct way that I
understand it.
And that that's an excellent summary of
what Dr. Wallach teaches has been
teaching us this whole time.
So, I mean
Anybody else want to jump in?
You'll know why I'm doing this in a in a
minute. Anybody else want to jump in?
My answer is pretty close to what AJ and
Albert said, so [laughter]
Is there anybody else?
All right, so um Okay, if if you don't
want to pull anybody else in,
let me just let me just give you a a
reason why I think this kind of varies.
And I'm going to bring other authors in,
not just Dr. Wall.
Okay.
>> Okay.
To go from our genes,
we all know that we have genes,
and in order for that genetic material,
that blueprint, to go on to our
offspring, those genes have to the the
helix has to open up,
and then we have to have messenger RNA,
and then the messenger RNA will go in,
and proteins will actually be created
according to that map or that blueprint.
So, we have the genes themselves.
They have to be able to duplicate
themselves, because they're in every
cell, virtually. I mean, we have red
blood cells and things that that don't
have them. But, the DNA have to be able
to replicate themselves through all of
the cells,
and there can be mistakes in that. Does
everybody kind of agree with that? We
can have mistakes in our cells. Okay, so
that's one place there can be mistakes.
Then, when we make the messenger RNA,
there can be mistakes going from the DNA
to the messenger RNA,
right? And then, from the messenger RNA
to go to the proteins, the actual
proteins themselves,
that can be a mistake.
So, when I think about epigenetics, and
again, I'm I'm not right. I'm just the
way I'm thinking about it,
there can be mistakes where the genes
are are incorrect. There's a mistake in
the gene going from one cell to another.
There can be a mistake in the messenger
RNA, and there can be a mistake in the
protein.
And how many proteins do we have?
Right?
Lots.
>> Trillions of them. I mean, we have we
have trillions of cells. We have all
these different So, all of these things
in all these places there can be
mistakes.
So, if we do the literal definition like
pretty much all of you guys and actually
myself in a way
where we don't change the DNA
but something downstream changed and we
have a protein that doesn't work or an
enzyme or you know, a a vital part of
the body that doesn't work correctly.
And then we're talking about how that
Epi Epi means above
or outside of genetics, right? So, those
are the things that happen.
But there's also the possibility like I
said that the gene itself can have a
problem.
And when that when you're doing that
and when I made a comment the last time
I was on and AJ and I were talking back
and forth and I made the comment we can
use nutrition to work around a genetic
defect.
And the reason I phrased it that way is
because with my own PhD research
there was a genetic defect
that actually affected the muscle cell
membranes of horses.
And because of that defect a protein
there I mean there was a protein created
and those horses had a bunch of
metabolic problems and what we did what
I actually did because it was my
research designed a way to use nutrition
to keep those horses alive even though
they had
defective proteins because of a
defective gene in one stallion.
Okay?
But most of the time when we think of
something like methylation
we think about people are not able to
manage the normal B vitamins
without that last step and it's just
adding methyl groups on. And most people
believe that what that does is turn
genes on or off.
That was the common way that people
looked at it before, because a gene
would either be on or off.
Now, it's gotten a lot more complicated
than that.
So,
I you know, I'm not sure that you we can
just say on and off, but
things are affected by it.
Okay?
So, any questions about that or comments
about that? And then I'm going to go
ahead and and just start through my
slides.
Anybody? I'll see if I can pull them
>> not see any. Let me check Facebook and
Rumble
and YouTube.
No No questions or comments yet. We're
good.
>> Okay. All right. So, everybody's
confused already.
Away we go. Okay. All right. So, what is
epigenetics? All right. We talked about
it.
Let's see if I can get that slide to go.
There we go. Okay. The term
epi means above, and genetics is the
study of genes and heredity. So, we kind
of know that. We've all had some
kind of a um in school in school one way
or place or another we've had
um
some we've learned something about
genetics, study of genes and heredity.
Okay.
Um
all of you brought in the environmental
and specifically nutrient effects on
genes, because again, you're right. This
is a huge thing. This is what Dr.
Wallach discovered.
Because if genes just determined
everything, which a lot of people have
always thought,
if if genes determined everything, then
we have no way to improve. We have no
way to help ourselves, and we are
literally stuck,
which is not a fun thing to believe.
As a person interested in nutrition my
whole life,
I don't know if I ever really believed
that the genes were in control of
everything.
I would have to think back a bunch, but
for a long time I have understood how
nutrition can affect things. So, that's
how it goes for me. Now, a lot of you
have probably heard people say Dr.
Wallach is considered to be the
co-founder or a co-founder of the
science of epigenetics.
So, I looked up and I have I already had
read this book. I had
was aware of Dr. Lipton.
He is a cell biologist
and he wrote a book in 2005
10th anniversary second edition 2015
called The Biology of Belief. I'm going
to go through and talk a little bit
about his book and then about Dr.
Wallach's book.
And the third thing on here, which we
can't get to today because
it will take, you know, it's a it's a
full presentation.
So, I'll have to do that another time,
but my research
what happened was there was this
stallion who had this defect and it
there's still
there there is a discussion about
whether that horse itself had the
genetic mutation or only his offspring
did.
Because the people never The people took
tests and knew, but never
never
divulged it, put it that way. But,
anyway,
so these these horses that were sired by
this stallion
could actually die
from heart failure because of too much
potassium in the blood.
And or they could have these strange
things where they would they would sit
down like a dog and they would they
would do what we call fasciculations.
So, again, that I've got to do
at another time, but I wanted to put it
up here because it's an example of a of
a workaround.
Whereas, you know, the other two,
Dr. Wallach would would um look at an
animal, I got all this stuff coming up
in the talk. He'd look at an animal,
maybe after it had died, find out what
was missing through the necropsy,
and then say, "Okay, if a bunch of
animals with these symptoms have this
same deficiency, then we know it's not
genetics, okay?" So, all of that
those of us that have followed this and
are familiar with this book and Dr.
Wallach's work,
that's kind of where we're going to, you
know, where we're coming from. Okay,
this is the book, The Biology of Belief,
second edition by Bruce Lipton, cell
biologist.
So, in 18 or 1985,
he basically said, "My research offered
incontrovertible proof that biology's
most cherished tenets,
in other words, what everybody believed
regarding genetic determinism, that you
were determined by your genes and
couldn't fix it or change it, were
fundamentally flawed."
So, that's the way he looks at this. And
by the title of the book, you know he is
looking at beliefs. And his his whole
book is really,
you you know, you are what you think,
that kind of a concept. So, I basically
just put what's he what he has in his
chapters. I'm not going to go through
this in detail. I have read most of the
book a while ago, a few years ago, and
it's it's amazing. I I recommend people
look at it if they're interested in it.
Um but I'm not, you know, I'm not ready
to go ahead and do a detailed thing
about it. But look, he's learning
from his smart from the cells in the
Petri dishes and his smart students.
What a concept. And then, it's the
environment, stupid, right? Where the
whole thing the original saying was,
"It's the economy, stupid," when it
comes to politics and things like that.
So, anyway,
about belief and how it affects those
things. And then,
also in his book, he's just he's just
going through this process. One thing I
found fascinating, in chapter seven he
talks about conscious parenting.
Are parents genetic engineers? But, he
brings some really good research,
scientific research in about, for
instance,
when if parents were fighting in front
of an unborn child,
that child reacted differently. It would
jerk, it would have changes in heart
rate and some things like that. So, he's
looking at a lot of environmental
things. People that are interested in
that, again, beliefs control behavior
and gene activity is is his basic
concept.
Okay, and here we go to Dr. Wallach's
epigenetics book.
And this is a this is the 2014, I
believe it's the I mean, it's been
reprinted a bunch of times. I don't
think there's a second edition.
572 pages pages, and this is Dr.
Wallach,
his wife, Malon, and
um Gerhard Schrauzer, and he was a
selenium researcher.
Very high in up in the field. So, this
is, you know, the three of them writing
this book together was a big
deal.
Okay, now the award there was an awards
committee
that
um the Biological Trace Elements
Research Institute in December 2011
uh announced that Dr. Wallach had won
the 2011 Klaus Schwarz Commemorative
Medal.
And this is what they said.
From a historical perspective, Wallach
is to be regarded as one of the first
practitioners, if not founders, of
epigenetics, the new research discipline
that investigates
quote heritable.
In other words, did the genes change or
did the genes not change?
Alterations in gene expression
caused by mechanisms other than DNA
sequence. So, there's a definition.
There's one of them that we can look at.
With the award of the Klaus Schwarz
Commemorative Medal, Wallach is
belatedly honored for a serendipitous
epigenetic discovery that will be of
benefit to many.
So, is that the is that the definition
that um
Marilyn, that you were using?
Doesn't matter. I mean, if she's if
she's not available.
Yes. Okay. Thank you.
Is that the one? Yes. That's from the
very beginning of the book. Okay.
So,
and again, that specifically says
without a change in the DNA. So, that
does not count when the DNA itself
itself gets changed rather than
something down line as far as, you know,
mRNA or protein or whatever. Okay. So,
why did Dr. Wallach write this book? I
think we understand that. He had to make
the point
and this is all my opinion.
He had to make the point that we can't
follow the gene theory. The gene theory
it has been found to be wrong and we
have to go on from it. We have to change
it.
So, he starts out with the seeds and
evolution of medical thinking.
And he goes back and it you know, those
of you who haven't read this book, if
you're if you're interested with in all
these things we do, it's fascinating
because he really brings in a lot of of
history and and um you know,
understanding as if you were in a
college course. I mean, this could be a
easily be a college textbook
on this topic.
So, when people don't understand what's
going on, they had no idea what germs
were. They didn't know things could be
so small that we couldn't see them and
they could that they could affect us.
And so, they were influenced by things
and they called them evil spirits.
And if you think an evil spirit is out
there and you're told this is how it
acts and this is what you have to do and
you know, you have rain dances and you
you just have the all these things going
on.
And then from there, again, myths and
things are what you get from the past,
from your history, from
your relatives, your tribe, whatever.
And alchemy was the idea that you could
change
People really wanted to try to change
other elements into gold. That was the
main one, but they wanted to change They
wanted to be able to change one element
to another and they they you know, they
thought, well, why can't we? Why can't
we change water to wine? Why can't we
change copper to gold? Whatever.
So, that was a belief. Well, now we
basically understand that those things
are done
with a chemical reaction, like a nuclear
reaction is what it would take.
And, you know,
so so we've kind of set that aside.
Now,
we get into the witchers the witches and
sorcerers and magic because what those
people did is they would have a way
of
They knew the people believed in these
myths and things. So, they figured,
okay, I'm going to be the one that does
that.
So, they tried to you know, they were
going to follow that and do it.
And I love the way his chapter four is
called physicians.
Because again, that is
a specific title that was put together
for people who are changing are trying
to change these things.
So, it's very interesting. Again, I'm
you know, I'm not going to go in huge
detail. It's a very long book.
But then we get to the age of vaccines
and antibiotics.
And this is where they start saying,
"Okay, we know what germs are.
We either have microscopes, I mean, they
did at that point have microscopes, but
we're able to see things moving around
at a in a smaller size with the
technology we have.
And
we have and at least
at a certain point they had what's
called Koch's postulates, k o c h.
And that was a person, a doctor, and he
said, um if something
can be is an infectious disease, you
have to be able to get it from a sick
person,
isolate it,
put it into a well person, and the well
person has to get sick.
So, that was the concept of Koch's
popula um
postulates. And what that means is um
for bacteria and things of a certain
size, things that are living organisms.
We know what bacteria are, they're
alive.
So, for something like that, Koch's
popula uh postulates made sense. When we
get to viruses,
viruses, the way we understand them,
they are only the genetic material,
but they cannot they're not alive
because they cannot reproduce without
being in a host.
And so, therefore, there are some people
out right now that have, you know,
I like to listen to a lot of different
points of view. There are people out
there right now that are saying, "Well,
there are no viruses because they don't
you can't use Koch's postulates because
if you take a virus from a sick person,
you have to grow it in tissue of
something.
Because it can't reproduce by itself.
And if you grow it in tissue, then you
haven't isolated it, which is true.
And and therefore, you can't follow
through and you can't use that
particular
process.
But, and here's where I'm going to come
back against that,
a virus can be there.
And if you inject
a virus
from one animal
into another species,
or actually even into the same species,
what you did is you took it from where
it was already infecting another body,
and you put it in and infected another
body,
and if that second body got sick with
the same
symptoms, you don't need Koch's
postulates.
Okay, so that's where that big thing is
going.
And it's going to be interesting to see
how people finally come up with that. Um
The other The other side of that, when
the people that say that there are no
viruses,
what they're saying is that something
that comes out of a cell that they can
see with an electron microscope that is
extremely small,
something coming out of a cell that we
might call a virus,
they are saying it's what's called an
exosome,
which means maybe your body is just
trying to get rid of something that it
doesn't need,
and that that exosome
is not actually a virus. It's not
contagious. It's just something that
we're getting rid of.
And there's another theory
with viruses, that they may actually be
a communication system.
They're so small, they go through the
air. They can literally get around the
world, even without airplanes,
and they may be an actual form of
communication.
So, those things are all out there. We
can think about those and think of, you
know, what do we think about it?
However, like I said, it has been proven
as far as my understanding because
something that we would call a virus
that has been photographed
has been injected from one person to
another and then the second people got
sick.
Okay, so that's all out there.
Um a real quick one on prions.
I don't know if how many people are
familiar with prions, but there are
there are multiple diseases.
Um and I did mention here, Dr. Wallach
did a did a great lecture talking about
chronic wasting disease in deer.
I am thinking it was a um video.
It may have only been audio. I think it
was video though.
And people that are interested in that
should take a look at that cuz it was
fascinating. Now, I believe
We did that on this show. Yes, I think
you did as a matter of fact. So, so you
guys can find it um and maybe let people
know because the the thing is
people are killing the deer. We have to
keep track every time we harvest a deer,
we have to keep track of it. We have to
be very careful when the deer are are um
butchered because
where where the prions occur are in the
central nervous system.
And so, you know, you've got to be
really careful to get the meat from the
deer without having brain or spinal
fluid with it.
And so, you know,
a butcher that didn't understand what
was going on here
could could spread it theoretically and
all these things. But, the point being
there and Dr. Wallach's
belief and understanding from what I
understand from listening to him
is that
prions are not
contagious. Again, a one deer cannot
give it to another deer, one person
cannot give it to another person, and
I'm going to go through his um
what he's saying here. But this is an
interesting quote. It's in the prions
chapter of epigenetics.
And this is just kind of him saying,
"Hey, I've been in this book, I've been
telling you guys why we have to change
our beliefs sometimes." And his quote
is, "The earth is not flat, the sun does
not rotate around the earth,
and prions cannot be infectious if they
cannot satisfy Koch's postulates." And I
love the way he does this here because I
just talked about it with viruses.
Because he's looking at, you know, this
is what they can and can't do.
And so he says, "Continuing to defend
the theory that BSE and CJD
are caused by um and transmitted by
prions is akin to defending the theory
that life and disease are the result of
spontaneous generation, which is what
people used to think in the past." And
I've got your what BSE and CJD are.
Bovine spongiform enceph- encephalitis,
it means in a cow a spongy-looking
um
inflammation of the brain. Okay, so they
also called it mad cow disease. In
people, it's called Creutzfeldt-Jakob
disease.
It's been found in the brains of people.
But what are prions actually?
Originally, they thought they were
misfolded proteins. Okay, so if you take
a protein, you have a big long
two-dimensional strand of the protein.
And then you can fold it and you have
these little ionic bonds between
different parts of the protein that that
will attach to each other and you get a
three-dimensional protein. And that's
extremely important. We need a lot of
our proteins need to be
three-dimensional. And then for one more
dimension, the four we call it a
four-dimensional protein.
Multiple [clears throat] proteins attach
with those bonds, those ionic bonds,
or or, you know, maybe a little stronger
bonds, covalent bonds,
and you have a four-dimensional protein.
And And classic examples of those are
heme, you have iron, and then you have
four molecules around it, and that
becomes heme, which carries oxygen in
your blood.
And then the other one is in plants. And
you have magnesium as the center, and
then you have those four folded
proteins, and you end up with
um
What did I just say?
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, in plants.
Everybody think of it.
Or I will in a second. Um to do
photosynthesis.
Okay?
You need magnesium instead of instead of
iron. I don't know why I'm blanking on
that. Okay.
So,
Okay, I don't want to go there yet.
Okay, so the idea with with prions was
originally
those thing They're misfolded proteins.
And what makes the most sense is that
once one protein would misfold,
then the one next to it would also
misfold, because as these ions go back
and forth,
that's, you know, that one ion next to
the next protein will go will twist back
and forth.
Okay? But again, it's not contagious.
It's not something that you can catch
like a germ.
And if people keep considering it to be
like prions to be like germs, then we
will have we have all these issues with
cattle, butchering of cattle, and
butchering of deer and things like that.
So, this is what Dr. Wallach is is
talking about in the prion channel. And
sorry if that's been confusing, but
it's one of those things. We change
as we learn new information, we change.
Okay.
Prions are from a copper deficiency.
This is where this is leading.
Because of the copper,
those proteins can't fold correctly, and
you can get this problem, and then it
just goes on. And that's why a person
who has this gets worse and worse and
worse.
And um so I'm going to go from from
there to just talk about copper
deficiency for a minute. Here we have
all a bunch of things that are caused by
a copper deficiency,
and you can look at these different
pages that I put on this slide um on
these pages 434 and 435, he's got a big
long list, two-page list of copper
deficiency things.
But since copper is required for
I think it said somewhere 400 enzymes,
400 different enzymes. I know zinc, they
talk a lot about 200 different enzymes,
but
we've talked about things in the past
with copper deficiency, and there are so
many of them. It's it's the classic
white, gray, or silver hair
because you need copper for the enzymes
that make the collagen,
and you need it for
the color that's going to go into your
hair,
the melanin pigment. I mean, it's needed
for so many things. So, your basic basic
arthritis, I'll just
list them here for people who are
listening but not watching.
So, we have arthritis, white, gray, or
silver hair.
In sheep, they can have straight what
they call steely wool, and we don't want
that because when you're raising sheep,
you you want normal wool.
And then wrinkles, connective tissue
diseases, vitiligo, and this is where
what Michael Jackson had, where he had
he should have had a dark complexion,
but he had spots that more and more
white spots.
Um ptosis is sagging. If you if you ever
know some you know, maybe an elderly
person or maybe someone with a bad
copper deficiency where the skin and
everything sags. When you look at them
and you see
that their skin sags in different parts
of the body.
Um
as [clears throat] we said anemia
because it's involved in the formation
of blood cells.
Um prions we've been talking about.
These are blood vessel problems. Spider
veins, varicose veins, hemorrhoids,
aneurysms and hernias.
It's actually involved in in hypo- and
hyper- thyroidism. So, copper is needed
for
normal thyroid metabolism. Not enough,
you can have either hyper or hypo.
Um ataxia which is a weakness.
And that he found in lambs.
Liver cirrhosis, just all these
different things.
So, again, people would see these
disorders or these things and think that
they were looking for a gene, but no,
they're really looking for a nutritional
deficiency.
Okay.
And then we get to the part three of the
book.
And here we're going the birth,
development, expre- and expression of
the genetic theory of life, disease, and
death.
And I think most people have heard of
Darwin's theory and it's basically
Darwin is Darwin is a kind of a
controversial thing because
he actually talked about one one type or
one species being better than another.
And he was kind of the father of
eugenics which was horrible.
But his idea was that species change
according to their environment. I think
we can all agree that species change
according to their environment.
But
it's more in fits and spurts of things
going on depending on environment.
So his theory, again, controversial.
People look at it one way or another,
but I think I don't think any of us are
going to, you know, believe in the whole
eugenics part of it. So
that said,
um and then Mendel was the monk who used
different colors and sh- and shorter
tall peas, garden peas,
and he would cross them and find out um
he figured out the the
um
recessive and dominance of genes. So if
we have
Okay, it looked like Dr. Judy has frozen
for all of you little minutes. Let's
give her a chance to come back.
Hopefully she will.
Yes.
All right.
I don't know about you guys, but I'm
finding this very fascinating and I hope
she comes back quickly.
It looked like she got kicked out and
she is
back with us. Let me find her.
>> Sorry, I should have mentioned that at
the beginning. That happened on the last
one and
>> Dr. Judy. random.
Can you hear me? Am I here?
You you left us for a few minutes. So um
All right, I'm going to just have you
spotlighted and remove myself.
Okay. Welcome back.
>> back. Yeah.
I apologize everybody. I live out in the
middle of the country and it just
randomly drops, literally.
So, I I've been lucky that when I'm
doing live presentations like this, this
is only the second time it's happened.
When I'm on a Zoom just watching or
something, it happens every once in a
while, but I honestly don't know how I
can prevent it, but I do come right back
on if possible. And we have sunny
weather right now, so let's hope we can
keep going. Okay.
So, I need to go back where
where I was talking about Darwin and
then Mendel.
Is that about where I was? Well, okay.
Mendel
was a monk
who did plant did botany research.
And he was famous for using plants that
were either short or tall,
pea plants.
Um they were either short or tall or
different colors. And so, he had
white and red
pea plants. And when he crossed them, he
actually got some pink.
Most of the time
you would have what, you know, what you
would call it would either be one or the
other.
But he happened to have one that's
called a codominant where when they're
together, they actually make a version
of both. They make like an intermediary
color. But anyway, he's the one that
taught us about dominant genes. So, if
there are two possibilities, two
alleles, when you cross them, you'll get
you'll get to see one, but not the
other. The one that you see is dominant.
And then the other one is recessive. And
if two recessives
if if two parents have the same
recessive, then you will see a new color
that you didn't see in the parents.
And that's the whole recessive thing.
And that's also the reason why we don't
inbreed within our animals and we you
know, most cultures have
um
taboos on marrying close relatives,
marrying you know,
cousins, brothers, sisters, whatever
because if there happened to be
traits that we both carry
and the offspring would get them both,
then we could end up with
something bad, you know, some kind of a
deformity.
That kind of thing. So, that was the
whole That was Mendel
figuring those things out.
And so, then
people, once they understood
that that animals could change over
time, Darwin, and that
there were different options
for colors and all these kinds of things
and that was Mendel, then they started
the genetic transmission theory.
So, again, once once we postulated what
genes were
then we got, well, maybe genes are
responsible for everything. Maybe
everything that happens
it has to do with it.
And of course, that's the that's the
main theory we're trying to go against
right now. Then along came Linus Pauling
and I'm going to talk a little bit bit
more about him in the next slide.
And the concept of the polymath is just
someone who researches so many different
topics and so many different
things that they are able to pull those
things together and have a very broad
understanding of things. And both
Linus Pauling and Dr. Wallach have been
constantly called polymaths because they
had that ability.
So, then we get to the double helix and
Watson and Crick were able to visualize
and prove the helical double helical
structure of DNA.
And then from then we wanted to go and
map the genome. So, they did that with
many different species of animals. And
the big surprise there with mapping the
genome was everybody figured, well,
human beings are so complex.
You know, they're so amazingly complex
that if an earthworm has 20,000
chromosomes,
humans must have millions, right?
Well, guess what? When they did map the
human genome, we don't have that many
more
than an earthworm.
Oops.
So, there has to be something going on
other than just those genes. The other
interesting thing about genetics was
that when they started to figure out
what the different genes work for.
So, you have something wrong, something
different with a person.
And then you try to go in their genes
and figure out where is there a change
that caused that problem? That's what
they're doing with mapping the gene.
Right?
So, they go in there,
but they only figured out what about 10%
of the genes
were for.
Now, obviously, you got to start
somewhere, you know.
But when they had 10% of the genes
figured out, they called all the other
90% of the genes junk genes.
Uh, probably not. You just don't know
what they are for yet. They're not junk.
But again, this is the this is science.
This is the process. How things change.
Now, let's go and and talk about um
Linus Pauling a little bit here.
And then we'll go on
with the book. Okay, and I used this
before, too, but um nearly all disease
can be traced to a nutritional
deficiency.
And this is a quote from Dr. Wallach's
book. But I recommend that people
interested in in Linus Pauling, there's
a great book that he wrote himself
called how to live longer and feel
better.
And he wrote it in 1986. And the
fascinating thing about that book is he
doesn't just talk about vitamin C. He
talks a lot like Dr. Wallach.
Already. I mean, you know, he was born
in 1901. But, he's talking about
essential nutrients and all kinds of
this stuff. So, people have figured it
out. But, did people flock behind Linus
Pauling and follow his advice?
No. Because he was doing something new
and different.
So, again, the lessons.
Okay, Linus Pauling, I put this in here
to show kind of the how this worked.
Sickle cell anemia was discovered
discovered and named in the black
population.
People with dark skin
that lived along the equator. It was
studied by Linus Pauling. He thought it
was a molecular disease. In other words,
he thought there was something to do
with molecules in there.
But, he didn't really know what was
going on with it. But, he thought it was
Everybody thinks it's genetic.
And by the way,
um Black Gene Lies, Dr. Wallach's book
Black Gene Lies,
I dug into there a little bit while I
was going through to do this
presentation. And
again, that that could be a textbook
that everybody should read.
It is literally a fascinating history.
And, you know, medical history, the
whole thing.
Anyway, along comes Joel Wallach and he
discovered sickle cell anemia in
white-tailed deer.
Well,
that tells you that it's not genetic
among human beings.
Right? It can't be.
He eventually found that it was caused
by a a selenium deficiency.
So, it's not genetically transmitted.
So, again, you'll you'll hear um
people will go in and get tested if they
have a family history of sickle cell
anemia, they'll go in and get tested and
things. No.
Once you have that sickle cell trait,
that was inherited.
Okay, I don't want to you know, that was
inherited, but
we can use nutrients now to make these
people's lives a lot
easier.
And the again, this is back to if the
mother had all the nutrients before
conception,
the idea is
they wouldn't get it.
Okay? No one would get sickle cell
anemia. It's just like all these other
things.
If the nutrients were there in the
mother, we could prevent all these birth
defects.
Okay? So, it's not genetically
transmitted the way the way people
thought. No. In other words, your genes
rule and if, you know, you're going to
get it if your mother had it, blah blah
blah.
Okay.
It's also called thalassemia
in the white population. So, it's not
even in I mean, it's not just the black
population and that's why Black Gene
Lies was such a great book and history
lesson there.
The other thing about sickle cell while
I'm while I'm talking about it is that
the the red blood cells shape weird.
And I finally found out why that
actually happens. The reason is that the
the sickle cell the sickle sickle shaped
cells
get stuck and clot together and and clog
capillaries and extremely painful.
You can lose um you know, fingers and
things because of no circulation into
the capillaries. But, the the reason it
never left the population
in places where there is malaria endemic
is that the sickle shape of the cells
confers an immunity or at least
partially
partial immunity to malaria because the
malaria
has to go into
that's the red blood cells and if
they're sickle shaped they're not big
enough for it to go all the way through
its life cycle and mature and hatch.
Fascinating.
So if you look at populations, usually
if there's something that is that is
bad, painful you know, can cause a lot
of damage to the body, things like that
like sickle cell, eventually it would
just come out of the population because
no one's selecting for it.
But when when those
people living there
are not getting malaria and dying like
the people who don't have it
again a fascinating population genetics
type thing. Okay.
So then we are going to the age of
biochemistry, nutrition and epigenetics
and here's where
the concept of it can't be just the
genes, there has to be environmental
effects and this is Dr. Wallach doing
this and then he talks about going to
the center um
for the biology of natural systems
and the 150 year update on the origin of
species where he goes back and talks
about the things that Darwin talked
about can't be right and I got a little
bit more detail on some of these.
Um
Okay, so the last chapters
he's just
going more into epigenetics
called the book nutrition the death of
the genetic um theory of disease
transmission and again back to Darwin
what's going on with survival of species
and things. But, I've got a couple other
just kind of ways to support what this
whole thing is about. Cardiovascular
disease
and this is from um this is kind of from
the intro the
towards beginning of that book.
Page 20.
Um
our 20th and 21st century doctors have
been saying all this stuff is genetic,
especially cardiovascular disease. It's
supposed to still be the number one
killer of people.
And Dr. Wallach is saying, "No, it's
caused by nutritional deficiencies." And
here are some cardiovascular disease
types and the nutritional deficiencies
that are a cause or that precipitate
symptoms.
Okay.
In the arteries
people are always talking about
inflammation.
Um I love it. I go on I go on listen to
people talk everywhere you can imagine.
And a lot of them start out with, "Well,
all the causes of disease, all the
problems, everything
all these issues that we have are all
because of inflammation." I hear that
all the time.
And my question is
what causes the inflammation?
Because inflammation is a normal process
that's required
to repair damages, damaged tissue and
things. So, inflammation itself is not
the bad guy. Everybody's trying to say
inflammation's the bad guy.
But, what causes the inflammation
or too much or prolonged inflammation,
chronic inflammation is again nutrient
deficiencies. So, that's my soapbox for
that.
Vitamin E, vitamin C, and selenium
protect the walls of your the your
arteries, the blood vessels
so that they don't leak, they don't
break, the walls are strong, they don't
break.
And since they hadn't didn't spring a
leak, they don't need to be plugged up
by whatever fat happens to be
circulating in the blood at the time.
We have cholesterol circulating in our
blood all the time if we're healthy,
but we also have
other types of fats going through our
bodies
from
denatured fats. If we If our fats get
too hot
in the process of extracting them from a
plant, for instance, corn oil gets
extracted at 400°, the fats are
denatured, the body can't get rid of
them.
They're going through the blood or the
lymph to get rid of them also, and we
can have issues for that.
So, that's one of the things that that
is a big deal in cardiovascular disease.
Now, when I when I mention these
individual nutrients, keep in mind,
we need all the 90, and we need them all
the time.
But, one of those 90 is going to show up
as missing first.
And when that happens, you get a certain
symptom.
So, that's why when we when we do talk
about one symptom, that doesn't mean
you're going to fix
a coronary thrombosis with a specific
omega-3 fatty acid.
You may be missing 50 of the 90,
but this is just the one that caused
that problem
right then, okay?
So, cardiomyopathy,
selenium.
Big news about cardiomyopathy in in the
news the last few years.
Congestive heart failure,
a thiamine deficiency, a B vitamin.
We already did the coronary thrombosis.
Aneurysms, one of the things we already
talked about with copper.
Lot of things cause copper.
I I remember
as a horse person, one of the one of the
worst things that could ever happen is a
mare
has a foal
and the pressure or the stress of her
pushing that foal out
she has an aneurysm and dies during
foaling and that's a copper deficiency.
It's a It's a really you know, it's a
bad one.
Okay, and then atrial fibrillation and
he goes through and talks about a bunch
of other things, but basically he was
talking about a calcium deficiency among
other things. It's It's your you know,
the nerves
the vagus nerve coming through the small
area in the back of your neck
coming down from your from the brain,
that nerve comes down and you get atrial
fibrillation because that nerve is
compressed because you don't have enough
calcium, you build too much bone in that
area and you know, so that's what it is
and what do they do? They take your
heart out of your chest, beat it with a
paddle, do all these things, but it's
not the heart that has a problem. It's
the nerve telling the heart
what to do. That's a famous story that
Dr. Wallach tells all the time.
Okay.
Mhm. Come on.
Sorry. I when I
my computer's asking me what I want to
do when I'm trying to change my slide.
All right.
And I wanted to throw a couple more of
these in. These are the ones we're
really familiar with if we've studied
Dr. Wallach very much.
Um I think there's an S I didn't spell
uric disease right, I don't think. I
think there's an S in there. Okay.
Um
cystic fibrosis, a horrific disease,
always they're still mostly talking
about it being
genetic.
But
non-related monkeys when Dr. Wallach was
there at the NASA center where they
raised the monkeys that were going to go
they were actually raised to go to
space.
But what he found is that a bunch of
unrelated, not you know, you couldn't
look at their bloodlines and go back
their pedigrees and go back for many
generations. And they had different
parents. So in other words, they weren't
brother, sister, mother, father, that
kind of thing.
They developed the same symptoms of
cystic fibrosis. And what this is is
is in the lungs, a whole bunch of mucus
is constantly being formed and you can't
get rid of it. And children that have
this had a short life expectancy, maybe
11, 12 years or something.
It was very bad.
So he discovered this in those monkeys
and because it was proven in both
monkeys and people,
he knew it wasn't genetics, so he
started trying to figure out what it was
and sure enough it was selenium. A lot
of things are caused by a deficit of
selenium and of course it was maternal
nutrition. The mothers didn't have it
enough selenium.
And so that function was lost, the
ability to clear the lungs of that
mucus. So that's the story of cystic
fibrosis and he lost his job and
everything
because people didn't want to believe
it. It's really difficult to teach
people to convince people that that
they're wrong about something that
they've believed. And here's just
another list of congenital birth defects
and some of the deficiencies are caused
by. This is from page I think it's 285
in epigenetics.
Cerebral palsy in a llama,
copper and zinc deficiency.
Spina bifida in a monkey, folic acid and
or zinc deficiency.
Cleft palates, we talked about the foxes
before,
where two parents had 10 foxes and the
olive cleft palates. That's imperfectly
forming the the the head and the jaw of
an animal
because of lack of nutrients and vitamin
A and zinc he found in the foxes were
deficient. And by changing those zoo
foxes to
a diet of dog food,
commercial dog food because commercial
dog food is fortified with all the basic
nutrients, he was able to fix that.
Ventricular septal heart defect in the
bottom of the heart, the two
ven- ventricles, the two chambers of the
heart, the septal is what goes down the
middle. There was a defect there. He
found it in the kangaroo.
And vitamin A and zinc fixed that also.
Okay, muscular dystrophy, the other huge
one that Dr. Wallach talks a lot about
that they found the problem, but no one
wanted to listen.
He found it in hatchling ostriches, wild
African sheep, vitamin E and selenium
issue,
and ruptured aneurysms, like I said with
the mare,
pheasants, ostriches, gorillas, squirrel
monkeys, and cop- and uh it's a copper
deficiency.
So, again,
epigenetics,
basically we're trying to figure out
why it is that it's that our genes don't
tell us every single thing,
and how
things can be
wrong
at all the different stages.
People are going to disagree a little
bit on the definition, but as far as
being able to help people with nutrition
when there are people and animals, when
there are problems with genetics, that's
what it's all about.
Okay, and I I have I just have to
mention, I know we're we're getting long
here already, but
I have to mention this and I would like
people who would be interested in doing
this with me. What I would really like
to do
is this is a fascinating PBS
video.
Um I believe it was 2015.
It is three basically three-hour-long
parts, but
they have technology where they are
looking inside
the womb
as
human babies develop.
And they go by week and at each week
certain thing they have examples of
people
where something interesting happened at
that time frame. And basically it tells
us if you're having an issue, it
happened at week this or if you another
issue, it happened at week that.
Obviously I can't talk about it like a
book because without the video, you
know,
it's not going to make any sense.
But what I want to do is I want to put a
group together that wants to watch this
as a series.
And I need to find out what issues there
would be with copyright.
I need to make sure that I can show the
video and talk about it with a group as
a teacher and have that work and I'm
seriously hoping that works. Any of you
that are curious enough can go you can
buy that video from PBS. You may be able
to buy it other places, but
it's absolutely fascinating and it shows
how some things that we see in nature
and in the last part of it, the the last
hour,
they even call it epigenetics.
One of the main things they talk about
is that in a certain place
the people who the babies who are born
in the spring
where the moms had
the the the best nutrition. There's a
huge difference between the spring when
there's good nutrition and then the
total drought dry area otherwise. Babies
born in that in the spring
can live to be 100 to 120. And I think
it's about 60 years.
A group of researchers have been
following these exact people.
The ones that are born at the other
times of the year when it's really dry,
and those babies during development are
not getting
what they need. The mom is not getting
the nutrients that the baby needs. And
you see a bunch of these different
changes, including
half as long. They live to be 60 rather
than 120. There are specific things that
happen to them. That's just one of the
fascinating things that they talk about
in this, so.
Just a thought.
And I'm ready for questions.
Awesome.
That
um was amazing, Dr. Judy. Thank you.
Join you on screen.
That
was
amazing. I had a couple like
when you talked about the worm,
I'm like,
oh my gosh, is that real?
But then when you talked about the
cystic fibrosis or sickle cell,
and
that
malaria couldn't get in there and and
and you know, hatch
mature.
Like, that's almost like a defense
mechanism that the body created for
people in that area.
That's just Right. It's It's like a
spont- something happened. This is why
there's diversity,
and and things can change. This is why
there are blue eyes and brown eyes, and
I mean, obviously. But yeah, that if an
accident or a mistake or something like
that doesn't happen, if all of us were
exactly the same, then one thing could
come along and it would wipe us all out,
right?
Yeah. Right. Good.
>> Malaria would kill all of us if we all
had
sickle cell or didn't have sickle cell.
That That's all And by the way,
chlorophyll, I'm sorry. Chlorophyll.
>> [laughter]
>> Chlorophyll is green. It has magnesium
in the center and it is used for
photosynthesis. I I just could not think
of chlorophyll.
What happens to you?
>> Marilyn, did you think of chlorophyll
when you were putting that in there? Did
that come to your mind?
Or you were so busy typing you it
didn't.
It did not.
Oh, that's fine.
>> not. That's too funny. Funny. Okay, go
ahead everybody. Okay, well, real quick.
Zizi Captain out there on YouTube in
YouTube land, like I like to call it.
So, whenever you see that, it's me.
>> [laughter]
>> He says
Hello there. He says, "Oh, where is it?
So sorry. I'm in the wrong section cuz
we put it all right here. He says, "Hi
CHN Nation. We love Dr. Judy Reynolds."
with a happy face and a thumbs up.
Thank you.
>> I
And he says or they say, "I think they
are underrated polymaths
in the world.
And he also or she also says, "I take
note when darling with Darwin's caveat,
it's not survival of the fittest. The
original was that nature eliminates the
weakest or when you're at your weakest."
And so, I just wanted to say that and
then Marilyn has her hand up and we have
a few other hands up and I will look for
more questions and we do have one asking
about how do you join
the video group, but I'm just assuming
let us know and then we can post it.
All right.
>> If you're interested, I would I would
send an email into Daily With Doc right
now because if we get a bunch of
interest in that, I have a feeling our
Daily With Doc people uh you know, a lot
of our people are going to want to do
this. So, I don't think it'll be you
know, nobody'll want to do it. But, if
anybody wants to get your name in there
so you don't forget.
Perfect. All right, Marilyn.
Go ahead. Um I just wanted to say about
It's interesting you're talking about
prions because I have this client that
does a lot of research. He's a little
scientist. And he's saying,
"Oh, I I think there might not be
viruses. There's really just prions. So,
I'm going to be sending him this
video from today.
And and convince him cuz now it is
debunked, right? It is debunked. It is
no longer
>> Well,
again, you you know, they're
You hate to say something is settled in
science, right? That's the whole thing.
People are going to disagree. Um if I if
I see a certain amount of proof of
something, yeah, I'm going to say I'm
pretty good. I'm not I don't have to go
looking for more answers.
But,
the whole the whole thing here is that
things change. We really believed
a lot of these things in the past. You
know, we believed the Earth was the
center of the universe.
You know, we we believed so many of
these things and then we when we get
more
understanding, more knowledge, more
technology is a big part of it. The
telescope, the microscope, you know,
when when we start getting these kinds
of things, that's how when we start to
be able to analyze blood,
then we learn so many more things than
we know knew before that. So, yeah.
>> trying to say that viruses are not
visible? Are Have they been seen?
Yes.
So, and see it See, I Okay, I just so
that this makes sense and why I even
jumped in there, because I think people
have to. You have to jump in there. Um
if you want to say, in my humble
opinion, if you want to say that viruses
don't exist. Okay, first of all, then
every viral disease that anybody ever
got never had it. They never had it.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. So, that's
kind of a, you know,
if you're going to say something that
most people believe exist does not, then
you got to have an alternate.
You got to have something else. You got
to You got to
Well, that's why he said it was the
prions. See? Yeah. But again, how are
you going to prove You got to prove that
it's prions, not um
the best place to go
for proof of viruses existing
is Dr. Judy Mikovits.
And she did She was a researcher, and
she
you know, she worked in the viral labs.
But there are photos
of
specific viruses.
And again, you know, that that leads
into a whole bunch of different things
about transmission.
But they have photos proving specific
viruses.
Now, there another caveat as I come in
here. There are some things that maybe
were not or are not viruses.
So, just because maybe one thing wasn't
virus doesn't mean there aren't any
viruses. And again, exosomes exist. In
other words, all it is If you took a
picture of a cell and a little piece of
the cell membrane, a little bud comes
off, and it goes out.
There are pictures of those, too.
But the pictures that I think prove that
viruses exist, or this particular virus
exists, is that not only do they have
the pictures,
but they got them from a person
that was sick.
And that was injected into a healthy
person and then that person got sick and
then they still got the same pictures.
Right? And those things exist out there.
Some people say, well, you know, again,
if I have no
no horse in the race, no dog in the
hunt, whatever you want to say on any of
this. I love it when something new
happens, but I'm not easily convinced.
It you know, I'm going to believe what I
believe cuz I had my background, I had
the you know, I've read and understood
what I understand, but if you come in
and you got an alternate, then I'm going
to think about the alternate. But if you
just come in and say no
or if you refuse to read the other
person's proof or the other person's,
you know, what they're saying about it,
then it makes illogical sense.
You know, it it it
>> you'd have to actually believe Judy's
pictures and say, oh yes, it's valid,
she didn't make them up, they're real.
So, another thing, belief comes into
play, yeah. Right. Or anybody else, you
know, I mean, there there's all kinds of
researchers out there.
But
I don't know.
Okay, thank you. There's certain topics
we can't talk much about, but
Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Thank you. Thank you, Marilyn. Thank you
for your questions.
All right, and Keely has her hand up and
then I have a question from Facebook.
Hi, Dr. Judy. How are you today?
>> I'm great.
>> I'm great. I'm great. I just want to
tell you are an amazing um an absolutely
blessed educator.
Um
I can't say enough about it. You are in
your prime.
Um and I'm so proud to listen to you. I
have a couple of statements too. You
know, like when people say autoimmune,
I cuz I listen to Dr. Mikovits all the
time and I listen to these labels.
Sometimes I just sort of wonder if
everything sort of gets thrown into that
category of viruses because they don't
have another pot in order to put it in.
So, some of this stuff gets mislabeled
and then they see it as a generalization
instead of specifics.
>> [clears throat]
>> Great point. You know, so I always sort
of stick that in the back of my head.
The other thing is, if anybody's
interested, she does Dr. Mikovits does
have a weekly podcast that she does and
she also um has her own website where
she actually teaches from and you can
take a look at what her science is and
she also will give you PDFs um if you
really want to dig into the science, but
you better get ready because you're
going to have to study it hard.
She is
um
well, you know, you use the term
polymath and things like that, but for
people who don't know who she is, she
has a photographic memory. She's a she
did biochemistry when there was no
biochemistry. I mean, she did she did
chemistry that has now become the
science of biochemistry, but she can she
can
cite pathways that make your head spin,
make my head spin.
And I mean, you know, I have the
biochemistry background and all that,
too, but she is an amazing person
because she does have that photographic
memory. So, but she's also
very ethical. I mean, she stood up she
stood up and said, "I will not be
unethical." And
you know, so but she has books out
that explain the whole thing. Her books
are actually legal documents that
explain the whole process.
Um
I've got them. I've read them. I, you
know, they're they're amazing. So, yes,
and she does Look, you can you can go
out and look
and find her, you know, I can I can get
to
get information. You probably can, too.
People contact you or me or somebody and
we can help you find her stuff. So, if
you're if you're really a nerd and you
really want to learn about chemistry,
the other thing that's great about her
is she works she also does work on
helping people with nutritional
solutions and things like that.
So.
And she's she's sort of a competitor.
She's sort of a competitor with us. But
she's got the same basic theories. It's
just that, you know, she works with she
has developed some other things and
works with people that have developed
other things.
But, you know,
nothing wrong with that, either. So.
Judy takes um Dr. Judy Mikovits takes
taking a deep dive to a whole totally
different level.
>> [laughter]
>> Right.
Yep.
>> I said no doubt about that. The The
other thing
is that
why is it do you believe that when, you
know, you take a look at this animal
science and when when all of that
knowledge that you just covered for us
in comparison to people, why do you
think the medical community had
dismissed it
instead of accepting it? Given the fact
that this was done with animals first.
It's just I mean, other than the
pharmaceutical thing, why do you think
that's still a premise today?
Well, I that's [clears throat] that's
the whole thing that we're fighting and
it's because of the siloing. They
separate us all into separate units of
everything. And and with me it's
I laugh all the time because people
think I'm like a veterinarian.
The animal science and veterinarian
fields are completely separate. At Texas
A&M, they had a veterinary school.
Um we we had access to all the medical
school stuff. And I used to go I used to
go to Baylor and and we'd go back and
forth with animal scientists,
veterinarians, and medical people all
the time. You know, you'd put them
together. But, they really pigeonhole
people, and the more you learn, the the
more specific you get, and the less
general you are.
So, it's it's a all a setup. That's why
with Dr. Wallach learning it from the
animals,
you can't help but think, well, that's
got to work for people, too.
But, nobody does both.
I mean,
That it it it really is. And when like
if you do degrees like I did,
because the first one I did was Well,
actually, the first one I went to a
junior college for the first 2 years,
and I was lucky enough to get in with
some nursing students. They did a bunch
of classes because they had a whole
group of nursing students. So, I was the
only not I wasn't going to become a
nurse, but I, you know, but I took the
class. I took anatomy and physiology and
all the biochemistries and chemistry and
all this kind of stuff with a bunch of
nurses. Then I went on to the
bachelor's. I got a bachelor's of
biology teaching.
So, basically, I learned the whole the
science of biology, but then when I went
up the next level,
I took animal science
and got the next degree in animal
science. So, I kind of
I threw out the plants, but I kept the
You know what I mean? I did the I did
the Biology was all of it. Then I did
the animal science. Then I did the
nutrition. So, by doing it that way, I
really got a broad background.
It was interesting because some of the
teachers there at Texas A&M,
they were really worried. They'd never
had a biology major come and do
try to do animal science and nutrition
before. So, they were worried that I
might not have gotten all the stuff I
needed to know
in biology.
So, they had me TA the nutrition class
and stuff like that, which was a great
opportunity for me. You know, it was an
extra opportunity for me. But then, I
managed to be one of the very few people
in the horse program that ever got A's
in both
the first and second part of physiology.
We had to do We did veterinary
physiology.
And, you know, these are all smart
people. They all went and and did a good
job, but I was one of the few I had a
better understanding of that than most
of the people there. Again, because I
had already done that, you know, I had
done the anatomy physiology. So, anyway,
it's it's because they separate us out.
And here's another thing we we all need
to work on this.
We should have access free
for to all of these journals.
Everybody should. Most people aren't
going to care. Most people aren't going
to want to do it. But we In order for me
to
look at journals when I was working
in industry, they paid for it all. And
we could go get whatever ever journals
we wanted to look at. And when I was at
a university, they paid for it. And you
can go look at them. But when you're an
individual person, retired like I am or
whatever,
I can't even have access to those
journals because I would have to pay
hundreds of dollars for each one just to
look up a topic here and there.
Most of these things, like when I talk
about the NRC nutrient requirements of
cats and dogs or horses or whatever,
those are government publications.
They're paid for by our government. They
should be free. Everybody should have
access to all of these journals and all
these things, and we don't. And that's a
way of keeping us
ignorant, you know, of us not
understanding, not knowing, not having
access to that information.
But what happens is you got people in
industry that have money, okay? They're
trying to sell you a product.
They put together a conference.
All the people's companies that they
work for pay for them to go to that
conference, right?
So, everybody does their little research
project, they take it to the conference,
they all present it, and it's all paid
for. It's paid for by the companies.
But then, if you want to get it, you got
to pay for it.
Somebody else has to pay for it.
You know, I mean, it's just we've got
we've got to figure out a way that
people can have access to everything.
Because then we could look at it all and
decide what's what makes sense and what
doesn't. That's my opinion.
Yeah, that's a that's a that's a great
point. I never really um thought I
thought of it that way. But what I just
I'm sort of befuddled with is how is it
given that we've dealt with all this
when they used animals in order to
create the pharmaceutical
drugs.
Mhm. I mean, so they used animals, but
they won't believe that what happens in
animals actually impacts and is the same
for human beings. It just seems like a
walking contradiction all over the
place.
Right.
And and I mean,
each animal species has different
reactions to different things. The
vitamin C is a huge
great example because we can't make
vitamin C. Neither can, you know, fruit
bats and
um
guinea pigs and you know, certain
animals can't make their own vitamin C.
And vitamin C is essential, we got to
have it.
So,
in other words, to learn about vitamin
C, the best way to learn about it is to
watch a goat. Because the sicker a goat
gets, the more vitamin C it makes all by
itself, and then it gets better.
So, that's how we find out how much
we're going to need.
You know, and and one of the things that
just came out recently is they're
finally realizing that if you're really,
really sick and dying,
an IV of vitamin C might just get you
through it.
That might be all you need to survive.
Sepsic septic shock
you know, some of these really bad
hospital patients.
And who's who talked about that many
years ago? Linus Pauling.
You know, so anyway.
>> [clears throat]
>> Yeah, well thank you very much. I
appreciate I appreciate you.
>> Thank you. Thank you for the comments
and the questions. It's you know, the
the most fun of
as far as I'm concerned and the best
part of this
is when we have interactions. And and I
know I tend to do a bunch of slides and
then and then we talk afterwards, but I
really think
the I you know, that way you can listen
to it and you can do it multiple times,
but I really think the group concept
and and going through that movie and
some other things that I want to do and
and AJ and I have been talking trying to
get something put together where
where we can do kind of group type
stuff. So let's see if we can get that
done and anybody that's interested in
that just let it be known.
You know, let let us know.
Um mine is mine is just Dr. Judy
Reynolds@gmail.com
d r
j u d y
r e y n o l d s @gmail.com and then in
the subject line of the email put d w d
or daily with doc so that I know
that you're not one of the people trying
to spam me.
>> [laughter]
>> Excellent. Well, thank you for all your
efforts. We appreciate it. Yep, thank
you.
Thank you, Keely.
That was amazing, Dr. Judy. And Corey C
here on Zoom says thanks, Dr. Judy. I
have the book epigenetics. I was
following along and taking more notes.
Fascinated. [clears throat]
Oh, great. Yes.
>> Good idea and thank you for letting us
know that. That's a great idea.
Thank you, Corey.
And um, you know, Nancy says restriction
of knowledge equals control.
Mhm.
Yes. So, thank you so much, Dr. Judy. It
was fantastic. Um,
I always love when you're on because
there's so much to learn and you
always blow my mind.
Always.
>> Thanks, Ruth Allen. And you guys do such
a great job. I mean, you're like my
you're like my other family.
Awesome. Thank you. I feel honored you
feel that way.
All right. So, um,
if I could get my co-host to come on
with me, we'll um, exit our in the
meeting and um,
I I could listen to you forever, I
swear.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> all right. So,
um, if you would like more information
or have a question, if well, um,
email info, correct, AJ? At Yeah.
At dailywithdr.com. I'm sorry, I took
that. Questions, questions.
>> Questions at No, for questions, yes.
Questions at dailywithdr.
com.
And then if you wanted to let us know
that you were interested in Dr. Judy's
um,
lecture that she's talking about and
spending time. So, that would be info,
correct? Or support? I think it's info.
Info@dailywithdr.com.
If you would like to talk to a co- um,
oh my gosh. To co-host, if you'd like to
talk to a certified holistic health
coach,
um, please call us at 855-
949-3377.
And again, I just need to say that this
program was for educational purposes
only and not meant to treat, diagnose,
or cure any diseases or replace the care
of your primary care physician.
Dr. Judy, thank you, thank you, thank
you. I can't wait till you're on next. I
will call you and we'll set something
up.
Um and then so on my screen we have Mary
who is
in here and she goes out to the
different platforms. She also helps
monitor the chat in here and brings
questions in.
And then we have Albert who is
the gatekeeper and
he is the one that you will talk to in
the middle of the night, but he lets
people in and then if he sees something
funny going on, he kicks you out.
And then we
We love it. And then we have Sherry
who's part of our tech crew and she
helps get the stream out, the things I
send her and then she sends it out and
she sets up, you know, Facebook and
Rumble and different things like that.
And then we have Miss Speedy Fingers
Marilyn who is doing dictation, looking
things up. I don't know how you do that
and keep the flow going at the same
time.
I think you're amazing.
And then we have AJ who's our digital
marketing director and he helps us get
out to all the different platforms and
sets a lot of things up for us so that
we could get the message
for Dr. Wallach and Dr. Judy and
out there to the world. So, thank you so
much for what you do, AJ.
Couldn't do it without you.
And then I'm Ruth Allen Sanchez. I'm the
executive marketing Sorry.
Executive production manager.
I'm a little tongue-tied. I think my
mind was blown too much.
>> [laughter]
>> Got to make fun of yourself, right?
Anyway, I'm the executive production
manager at Dead Doctors Don't Lie Becca.
And um
I'm just grateful that you all joined us
today and thanks for hanging in. We went
a little long, but it was well, well
worth it.
So grateful.
And again a shout-out to Becca Dukes. We
love you. We miss you.
Look forward to you when you come back.
And um, always remember
to be kind.
Just be kind. You don't know what
somebody's going through.
And, um, you don't know what kind of day
they had.
Or what they're going home to. So, be
kind.
Thank you, everybody. It was great being
here. Again, thank you, Dr. Judy. And we
will see you tomorrow with Pharmacist
Ben.
See you then.
>> [music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
[music] the individual. Results vary and
may not be typical. We do not make any
claims regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. [music] Joel Wallach,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterinary Medicine,
four post-doctorates in pathology, and
naturopathic doctor.
>> [music]
>> Mhm.